Okay. So last time we looked
at and played this game,
you have to choose grades as you,
so you have to choose alpha and Beta.
And this table told us what
outcome would arise in particular,
what grade you would get and what grade
your pair would get. So for example,
if you'd chosen visa and
your pad shows an Alpha,
then you would get a c and
your path would get an a.
And one of the first things we pointed
out is that this is not quite a game yet.
It's missing something.
This has outcomes and it's,
it's an outcome
may tricks,
but it doesn't the game because
per game we need to know payoffs.
Okay? And then we looked at some
possible payoffs and now it is a game.
So this is a game is to give you some
more jargon. This is a normal form game.
And here we've assumed the payoffs are
those that arise if players only care
about their own grades,
which I think was true for a lot of you,
it wasn't true for the gentleman.
He's sitting there now.
But it was true for a lot of people.
All right,
and when pointed out that in this game,
Alpha strictly dominates pizza.
What do we mean by that? We mean
that no, if these are your pay offs,
no matter what your pair does,
you attain a higher payoff from
choosing Alpha than you do from choosing
[inaudible].
Right?
Let's focus a couple of lessons of the
class before I come back to this one
lesson was do not play a
strictly dominated strategy ever.
I remember that lesson and then much
later on when we looked at some more
complicated payoffs and a more complicated
game, we looked at a different lesson,
which was this,
put yourself in others shoes to try and
figure out what they're going to do.
All right,
so in fact,
what we learned from that is it doesn't
just matter what your pay offs to other.
That's obviously important.
It's also important what other people's
pay offs are because you want to try and
figure out what they're gonna do and
then respond appropriately. All right,
so we're going to return to both
of these lessons today, right?
Both these bathrooms will reoccur today.
Now a lot of today is going
to be fairly abstract,
so I just want to remind you that game
theory has some real world relevance,
and again,
it's done in the interest of recapping.
This particular game is called the
prisoner's dilemma. It's written there,
the prisoner's dilemma. All right, let's
just, it's prisoners, plural, and I,
we mentioned two examples last time.
Let me just reiterate and mentioned some
more examples which actually written
here so they'll find their way
into your notes. So for example,
if you have a joint project
that you're working on,
perhaps it's a homework assignment,
or perhaps it's a video project like
these guys that can turn into a prisoner's
dilemma. Why? Because each individual
might have an incentive to shirk.
All right?
Price competition.
Two firms competing with one another
in prices can have a prisoner's dilemma
aspects about it. Why? Because
no matter how the other,
from your competitor prices,
you might have an incentive to undercut
them if both firms behave that way,
prices will get driven down
towards marginal costs at industry.
Profits will suffer in the first case.
If everyone shirks you end up with a
bad product. In the second case, if,
if both firms undercut each other,
you end up with low prices that actually
good for consumers, but bad for firms,
and let me mention a third
example. Suppose there's a
common resource out there.
Maybe it's a fish dock or maybe
it's the atmosphere, right?
There's a prisoner's
dilemma aspect to this too.
You might have an incentive to overfish.
Why?
Because if the other countries with
this fish stock and see the fish Tacos,
the Atlantic, if the other countries
are going to fish as normal,
you may as well may as well fish as normal
too and at the other countries aren't
going to cut down on their fishing.
Then you want to catch the fish now
because there aren't going to be any there
tomorrow.
Right.
Another example of this referral would
be global warming and carbon emissions.
Again,
leaving aside the science about which
I'm sure some of you know more than me
here, the the issue of carbon
emissions is a prisoner's dilemma.
Each of us individually has an incentive
to it to emit carbons as usual. Right?
If everyone else is cutting down item have
to and if everyone else does cut down,
I don't have to. I end up using hot water
and driving a big car and so on. Right?
In each of these cases we
end up with a bad outcome,
so this is socially important.
It is not just some abstract thing going
on in the class and Yale and we know we
need to think about solutions to this.
Right from the start of the class and
we already talked about something,
we pointed out that this is not
just a failure of communication,
right? Communication per se will not
get you out of a prisoner's dilemma.
You can talk about it as much as you like,
but as long as you're going to go home
and still drive your hammer and have six
16 hot showers a day, we're still
going to have high carbon emissions.
You can talk about working hard
on your joint problem set, right,
but as long as you go home and don't
work hard, it doesn't help. All right.
In fact, if the other person is working
hard or is cutting back on their carbon
emissions,
you have every,
every bit more incentive to not work
hard or keyboard high carbon emissions
yourself. So we need something more
and kind of things. We can see more,
we can think about contracts, we can
think about treaties between countries.
We can think about regulation.
All of these things work
by changing the payoffs,
not just talking about it,
but actually changing the outcomes
actually and changing the payoffs, right?
Changing the incentives, right? And
important. Another thing we can do,
very important thing is we can think
about changing the game into a game of
repeated interaction and seeing how
much that helps and we'll come back and
revisit that later in the class. And
one last thing we could think of doing,
but we have to be a bit careful here,
is we could think about changing
the payoffs by education.
I think of that as the Maoists strategy,
right?
Lock people up in classrooms and tell
them how to be better people that may or
may not work and not optimistic, but
at least it's the same idea. What?
Changing payoffs.
Okay.
All right, so that's
enough for, uh, for recap.
I want to move on now and in particular
we left you hanging at the end last time
we played a game at the very end last
time where each of you shows a number.
All right?
All of you chose a number and we said
the window was going to be the person who
gets closer to two thirds
of the average in the class.
Now we've figured that out.
We figured out who the winner is and I
knew what all of you have or trying to
see if you want. Is that right? And I'm
going to leave you in suspense. Okay?
So I'm going to tell you today,
why don't we did figure it
out and we'll get there.
But I want to do a little
bit of work first. All right?
So just going to leave it in suspense.
That'll stop you walking out early.
If you want win,
win the prize.
All right.
So do me, lots of times in this
class, when we get to play games,
we get to have classroom
discussions and so on.
But there's gotta be some times when
we have to slow down and do some work.
And the next 20 minutes are
going to be that. All right?
So with apologies for being a
bit more boring for 20 minutes,
let's do something we'll call formal stuff
in particular.
I wanted to develop and make sure we
all understand what are the ingredients,
what are the ingredients?
All the game.
All right?
So in particular,
we need to figure out what formerly make
something into a game and the formal
parts of a game of this.
We need players.
All right? And while we're here,
let's develop some notation.
So the standard notation,
the players,
I'm going to use things like
little I and little j. All right?
So in that numbers game,
the game,
when all of you wrote down a number and
handed it in, at the end of last time,
the players were who hires were you,
right? You all with the players, right?
Useful texts and expression.
Meaning you plural.
Right? And the numbers game, we
give him something more on the here
and the numbers game
you will with a players.
All right.
Second Ingredient took the game.
Ela Strategies.
That's a good clue here. If I'm writing,
you should be writing. Okay. Strategies.
All right, notation. All right,
so I'm going to use little s,
little SSI to be a particular,
can I
strategy
off player I
particular strategy of player I so an
example in that game might have been
choosing the number 13 all
right, everyone understand that?
Now I need to distinguish this from the
set of possible Spanish is of player I.
So I'm going to use
capital SSI to be what?
To be to be the set,
the set, all alternatives. The
set of possible strategies.
Yeah.
Oh,
of player I.
So in that game we played at the end last
time. What were the set of strategies?
They were the set one,
two,
three all the way up to 100 all right.
So I'm distinguishing APP
ticket, a strategy from the
set of possible strategies.
And while we're here,
I want a third mutation for strategy.
I'm going to use little s without
an eye. All right? No subscripts,
but less without an eye to mean
a particular play of the game.
Yeah,
particular play.
Okay.
Oh, of the game. So what do I mean
by that? All of you at the end,
last time wrote down this
number and handed the man's,
we had one number per one strategy choice,
pepper for each player and each
person in the class. So here they are.
Here's my, uh, collected in
instead of strategy choices,
here's the bumble bits of
paper you hand in last time.
This is a particular play of the game.
All right,
I've got you the person's name and
I've got a number from each person.
A strategy from each person.
All right?
We actually have it on
a spreadsheet as well.
So here it is written out in a
spreadsheet, right? Each of you, each,
your name is on the spreadsheet and
the number you chose. All right?
So that's a particular player of the game.
And that has a different name.
We sometimes call this
a strategy profile.
So you're in the textbook.
You'll sometimes see the term a strategy
profile or a strategy backdoor strategy
list.
It doesn't really matter what is saying
is one strategy for each player in the
game. All right? So in the numbers game,
this is the spreadsheet.
One example of this.
Yes, the spreadsheet, right?
How does that make sense?
You can still see that I'm
going to pull down these boards,
okay.
And let me clean something.
So you might think what Don,
right, we've got a players,
we've got the choices they could make.
That's their strategy sense.
We've got those individual strategies
and we've got the choices they actually
did make.
That's the strategy profile.
Seems like we've got everything you
could possibly want to describe. Again,
what are we missing here?
Say shout it out. Pay Offs.
We're missing payoffs, right?
So to complete the game
we need,
we need payoffs. Alright. And again,
I need to Taishan the payoffs.
So in this course I'll try and
use you for you tile to be player.
Eyes playoff. All right? So you,
I will depend on play a one's choice.
All the way to play eyes own choice
all the way out to play at EMS choices,
right? So, uh,
plant eyes off the Ui depends on all
the choices in the class in this case,
including his own choice.
And of course a shorter way of writing
that would be Ui s it depends on the
profile. All right, so in
the numbers game, what is,
this is a numbers game.
Ui of ass can be two things.
It can be
$5 minus your era in pennies
if you won.
I guess it can be something as it was
a tie went by the writing that now and
it's going to be zero otherwise.
All right,
so we've now got all of the ingredients,
the game players, strategists,
payoffs.
All right,
now we're going to make an assumption
today and for the next 10 weeks or so.
All right, so, but almost all the class,
we're going to assume
that these are known.
Yeah,
we're going to assume that everybody knows
the possible strategies everyone else
could choose and everyone
knows everyone else's payoffs.
Now that's not a very realistic assumption
and we are going to come back and
challenge it at the end of the semester.
But this will be complicated enough to
get us a lot of material in the next 10
weeks.
I need one more piece of notation
and then we can get
back to having some fun.
So one more piece of mutation.
I'm going to write x minus I to mean
what it's going to mean a strategy choice
for everybody except person I it's gonna
be useful to have that rotation around.
All right,
so this is,
this is
hey,
choice
for all.
Excellent.
Yeah,
person I apply.
So in particular if you're person
one than that and then s minus,
I would be s two s three s four up to sn,
but it wouldn't include as one.
All right. It's useful. Why?
Because sometimes it's useful
to think about the payoffs.
I was coming from his own choice
and everyone else's choices.
It's just a useful way of
thinking about things. All right.
Now this one I want to stop for a second
and I know that some of you from past
experience are somewhat math phobic.
You do not have to wave your hands
in the air if your math phobic.
But since some of you are, let me just
get your water, take a deep breath.
This goes to people who are
math phobic at home, too high.
So everyone's like a slight panic.
Now you know you came here today,
your thought everything's gonna be fine.
Now I'm putting math on the board.
All right, take a deep breath. It's
not that hard. And in particular,
notice that all in doing here
is writing down mutation.
It's actually no math
going on here at all.
I'm just developing notation and I don't
want anybody to quit this class cause
they worried about math or math notation.
So if you are in that category of somebody
who might quit it because of that,
come and talk to me. Come and talk to
the AES. We will get you through it.
All right? It's fine to be math phobic.
I'm, I'm phobic of all sorts of things.
All right? Not necessarily math,
but all sorts of things. All right,
so serious thing. A lot of people get put
off meditation. It looks scary. That is,
there's nothing going on here except
for the station at this point.
All right, so let's have an
example to help us fix some ideas.
And again, I'll have to clean
the boards. So give me a second.
I think an example might help those
people who are disturbed by the mutation.
Yeah.
So here's a game
which we're going to discuss briefly.
It involves two players
and we'll call the players.
One.
I'm two and play a one has two choices,
top and bottom,
and play a two has three choices,
left center and right.
All right.
And so spray simple
abstract example for now.
And let's suppose the
payoffs are like this,
they're not particularly interesting.
We're just gonna do it for the purpose of,
of, of a illustration.
Here are the payoffs.
Five minus 1300640220.
All right, let's just map the notation
we just developed into this game.
Okay. So first of all, who
are the players here? Alright,
well there's no secret there. The
players are just writing down what, wait,
why don't we,
the players here in this game,
our player one and player two.
All right,
what about the strategy sets?
What about the strategy sense or the
strategy? Alternatives? All right,
so here, player ones, strategy set,
she has two choices.
Top,
well bottom represented by the
rows which are healthfully,
the top row and the bottom row right?
And play a two.
Okay.
Has to, Cha has three choices,
right? This game is not symmetric,
so they have different numbers
of traces that spine play.
A two has three choices,
left center and right represented by
the left center and right column in the
Matrix. And just to point
out, in passing up to now,
we've been looking mostly
at symmetric games.
Notice this game is not symmetric
and the payoffs or in the strategies,
there's no particular reason why games
have to be symmetric and pay offs.
All right, so again, this is not
rocket science, but let's do it anyway.
So just an example of payoffs.
So player one's payoff if she chooses
top and play a to choose his sensor.
We read by looking at the top row and
the center column and play a ones pay off
is the first of these payoffs.
So it's 11. All right.
And play a Tuesday off from the
same choices. Top four player,
one center for player too.
Again,
we go along the top row and the
center column. But this time,
which you'd pay a Tuesday,
offer to the second pay off.
Sorry. It's three. Okay.
All right.
So again,
I'm hoping that he's calming down
the math phobics in the room.
Now how do we think this
game is gonna be played?
There's no particular interesting
game at while we're here.
Why don't we just discuss it for
a second. All right, so if the,
if our make guys get a little
bit ready here. All right,
so how do we think this
game should be played? Ah,
well let's ask, uh, uh, somebody
at random, at perhaps hourly.
Do you want to ask, uh, this guy in
the blue shirt here, right? Uh, does,
does play a one here. Just play
a one. Have a dominated strategy.
Alright. No player one doesn't have
a dominated strategy. For instance,
if a player two picks left and
player one wants to pick bottom,
but if Claire to pick center player one
wants to pick center. Good. Very good.
I should let
you stand up. I forgot that.
Never mind. But that was very
clear. Thank you. And, and,
and was that loud enough? People
are to hear it. Do people hear that?
People in the back, you hear it. So even
that wasn't loud enough. Okay. So we need,
we really need to get people to,
that was very clear and very nice.
Will you want to stand up and shout?
All the people at the back can't hear.
So what I'm gonna do on your
name is Patrick and Patrick
said was no play at one
does not have a dominator strategy.
Top is better than bottom
against left cause. Sorry.
Bottom is better than top against
laugh because six is bigger than five.
But top is better than bottom against
center because 11 is bigger than zero.
Everyone see that? Alright,
so it's not the case.
That top always beats is not the top,
always does better than bottom or that
bottom always does better than top. Okay.
What about a bit raised hands this time?
What about player to just play a,
to have a dominated,
everyone's keeping their hands firmly
down so as not to get spotted here.
Should we, we uh, yeah.
Should we try a I like can we try this
guy and why you want to stand up and wait
for and against that and
really yell it out now louder
I believe right is a dominant strategy
because of player one chooses top. Uh,
then player two will choose center.
And if or I'm getting confused
now it looks better on my
paper, but yeah, at play,
right is never the best choice.
Okay, good. Good. Let's be a
little bit careful here. So
your name is Thomas Thomas.
So Thomas said something which was true,
but it doesn't quite match with the
definition of a domination strategy.
What Thomas stayed was right is
never a best choice. That's true.
That's true. All right. But
to be a domination strategy,
we need something else.
We need that.
There's another strategy of a play or two
that always does better right now that
have turned out to be true in this
game, but it's a seat. All right,
so in this particular game,
I claim that sensor dominates,
right? Which center dominates, right?
Just to see that if play a one
shows top sensa yields free,
right?
Yield zero three is bigger than zero,
and if player one chooses bottom,
then center yields to right yields
zero two is bigger than zero again.
So in this game sensor strictly
dominates, right? All right,
well what you said was true,
but I wanted to tell me specifically about
about a domination here. All right, so,
uh,
what we know here,
we know that player to should
not shoes should not choose,
right?
All right.
Now that's as far as we can
get with dominance arguments
in this particular game.
But nevertheless, let's just stick
with it a second. I gave you the door,
I gave you the definition of strict
dominance last time and it's also on the
handout by the way,
the hand out on the web.
But let me write that definition again.
Using or making use of the
mutation from the class.
So definition. All right. So player,
I play an eyes
strategy.
Yes.
Nicholi prime.
All right.
Is strictly
dominated by
play eyes.
Okay.
Strategy s Aye.
If not,
we can use on rotation if you are I from
choosing s when all the people choose s
minus Pi is strictly bigger than you.
I S I prime when other
people choose as my,
the PSI and the key part,
the definition is for all x minus sign.
Alright.
All right.
So just say it in words.
Pyre I strategy SEI prime is
strictly dominated by her strategy.
Ssi.
If s I always does split me better.
Always yields a higher pay off a player.
I,
no matter what the other people do
answer this is the same definition we saw
last time. Just being a little bit more
nerdy and putting it in, in some, uh,
some notation. Okay. People
panicking about that.
People look like deer in the headlights
yet. No, I'm gonna let you get a correct.
Alright.
Alright,
let's have a look at another
example. People, okay,
I can move this.
All right.
So it's not a slightly more
exciting example now. So, uh,
imagine the following example.
An invader is thinking about invading
a country and there are two ways that
would have two passes if you like,
through which he can
lead his army and you,
you are the defender of this country
and you have to decide which of these
passes or which of these routes into
the country you're going to choose to
defend.
And the catch is you can only defend
one of these two routes, right?
It's if you want to a real
world example of this,
think about the third century BC and
can someone can correct me afterwards.
I think if the third century BC, when
Hannibal is thinking of crossing the Alex,
right? Not Hannibal, Hannibal
Lecter Hannibal, the general
in the third century BC,
the one with the
elephants. All right. Okay.
So the key here is going to
be that there are two passes.
One of these passes is a hard part that
goes over the Alps and the other one is
an easy pass. It goes
along the coast. All right?
If the invader chooses the hard pass,
he will lose one battalion of his army
simply in getting over the mountains.
Something going through the hard past.
Alright, add. If he meets your army,
whichever party chooses,
if he meets your army defending a past,
then he'll lose another battalion.
All right, I'll, I haven't given you,
I've given you roughly the choices. The
choices are going to be for the attacker,
which to choose and for the defender,
which pass to defend.
But let's put down some payoffs so
we can start talking about this.
Why you in this game,
the payoffs for this game,
I'm going to be as follows,
such a simple two by two game.
This is going to be the attacker.
This is Hannibal and this is
going to be deep offender.
And I forgotten which general
was defending and someone's
about to tell me that
dam and there are two palaces.
You could defend the easy
pass or the hard pass on.
There's two of you could use to attack
through easy or hard. And again,
easy past here just means no mountains.
We're not talking about something
on the New Jersey turnpike.
So the payoffs here,
yeah,
are as follows,
and I'll explain them in a second.
All right,
so here's pay off.
The attacker's payoff is how many
battalions that he get to bring into your
country. He only has two
to start with. And for you,
it's how many battalions
of his get destroyed.
So just I just give an example.
If he goes through the hard pass
and you defend the hard pass,
he loses one of those battalions going
over the mountains and the other one
cause you meet you.
So he has none left and you find it just
dropped to destroy two of them, right?
Conversely, if he goes on the hard
past and you defend the easy past,
he's going to lose one of those
battalions. Or how have one left?
You lost it in the mountains.
But that's the only one who's going to
lose because you were defending the wrong
past. All everyone understand
the payoffs of this game?
Yeah.
All right. So now imagine
yourself has a Roman general, hi,
this is gonna be a little bit
of a stretch of imagination,
but imagine yourself as a Roman general.
And let's figure out what you're
going to do. You're the defender.
What are you going to do?
All right,
so let's have a show of hands.
How many of you think you
should defend the easy pass?
Raise your hand. Just raise
your hand. Soap, soap. So Jude
can see the, keep them up.
Weigh them in the air, but emotion
right in the air. What your flags. Okay,
because these are the Romans
defending the easy pass.
And how many of you think you're
going to defend the hard pass?
We have a huge number of people who
don't want to be Roman generals here.
All right, let's try it again.
No abstentions, right? I'm
not going to penalize you.
Get in the wrong item set.
All right,
so how many of you think are
going to defend the easy pass?
Raise your hands again and how many
think you're gonna defend the hard pass?
Hi, we have a majority choosing. Easy
Pass. I had a lot. A large majority.
So what's going on here?
Is it the case?
Is it the case that defending the easy
pass dominates defending the hard pass?
Is that the case?
Is the case that pending the easy
pass dominates defending the hot pass.
You can shout out, no, it's
not in a facts and facts.
We could check that at the attacker
attacks through the easy pass.
Not surprisingly, you do better if you
defend the easy pass on the hard pass,
one versus their sorrow.
But if the attacker was to
attack through the hard pass,
again,
not surprisingly,
you do better if you defend the hard
pass down the easy pass. All right? It's,
that's not hot. Not, not
an unintuitive a finding.
It isn't the case that he defending
easy dominates defending hard.
You just want to match with the attacker.
Nevertheless,
almost all of you chose easy.
What's going on?
Can someone tell me what's going on?
Let's get the mics going a second.
So can we catch the guy with uh, uh,
yeah. Can we catch this guy with a beard?
If we'll just wait for the
mic to get there. And if you
could stand up, stand up,
stand up and up and shout.
There you go.
Because you want to minimize
the amount of, uh, an, uh,
of enemy soldiers that reach Rome or
whatever the location is. All right.
You want to minimize the number of
soldiers that reach Rome. That's true.
On the other hand,
we've just argued that you don't
have a dominant strategy here.
It's not the case that
easy dominates hard.
What else could be going
on while we've got you out?
What do we get the other guy who's got
his hand up there and the metal and again,
stand up and shout on that Mike
points your Facebook might get.
Um, it seems, it seems
as though, uh, while,
while you don't have a,
you don't have a dominating strategy,
it seems like Hannibal is, uh,
is better off attacking through.
It seems like he would
attack through the easy pass.
Good. Why does it seem that,
I guess that's, that's right.
We're on the right lines now.
Why does it,
why does it seem like he's
going to talk for the easy pass?
Well, if you're not defending
the easy path he got, he doesn't,
he doesn't lose anyone. And if he
attacks through the the hard pass,
he's going to lose at least one battalion.
All right? All right, so let's have a
look at it from, let's do the exercise.
Let's do the second lesson
by emphasizing the beginning.
Let's put ourselves in Hannibal shoes.
That probably boots or something.
I had no wait. Whatever you do in your
writing an elephant, whatever you were,
all right,
let's put ourselves in the Hannibal shoes
and try and figure out what Hannibal's
going to do here. All right, so it could
be it from the animal's point of view,
he doesn't know which parts
you're going to defend. All right?
But let's have a look what happened.
Look at, look at his payoffs. If he, uh,
if you were to defend,
if you were to defend the easy pass
and he goes through the easy pass,
he will get into your
country with one battalion.
And that's the same as he
would have got if he were,
if he went through the hard parts.
So if you defend the easy
pass from his point of view,
it doesn't matter whether
he chooses the easy pass,
he gets one in there or the hard pass,
he gets one in there.
But if you were to defend the hard past,
if you were to defend the mountains,
then if he chooses the easy pass,
he gets both battalions in and
if he chooses the hard pass,
he gets new battalions in. All right,
so in this case, easiest better.
And we have to be live at careful.
It's not the case that for Hannibal
easy choosing the easy pass to attack
through strictly dominates
choosing the hard pass.
But it is the case that there's
a week notion of domination.
Here it is the case of
new introducing jargon.
It is the case that the easy pass for
the attacker weekly dominates the hard
pass for the attacker.
What do we mean by weekly dominates?
It means by choosing the easy
pass he does at least as well.
And sometimes better than he would
have done had he chosen the hard pos.
All right, so here we have a second
definition. A new definition for today
and again we can use
our jargon definition.
Yeah,
player.
Oh eyes
strategy.
Yes.
I prime is weekly
dominated by her strategy
as I,
if I'm going to take
advantage of annotation,
if player eyes payoff from choosing s I
against s minus sy is always as big as
all equal to her pay off from choosing
s I prime against s minus I and this has
to be true for all things,
but anyone else could do.
And in addition
player eyes payoff from choosing s I
against as minus side is strictly better
than a payoff from choosing sia prime
against s minus PSI for at least one
thing. Whatever else could
do. Fine. So just check.
That's exactly corresponds to the easy
and hard thing we just had before.
I'll say it again,
play I strategy sie prime is
weekly dominated by our strategy.
SSI,
if she always does at least as well
by choosing Sei than choosing us.
I prime regardless of what anyone else
does and sometimes she does strictly
better.
All right.
And it seems a pretty powerful
lesson that just as we said,
you should never choose a
strictly domination strategy.
You're probably never going to choose
a weekly dominated strategy either,
but it's a little more subtle.
All right. Now that definition,
if you're worried about what I've written
down here and you want to see it in
words on the handout I've already put
on the web that has the summary of the
first pass,
I included this definition in words as
well to compare the definition and words
with what's written here in the
nerdy notation on the board.
Right now, since we think
that Hannibal, the attacker,
is not going to play a
weekly dominated strategy,
we think that Hannibal is not
going to choose the hard pass.
He's going to attack on the easy pass.
And given that which should we defend,
we should defend it easy, which is
what most of you shows. So be honest.
Now was that way. Most of you chose
easy. Yeah, probably was right.
You might be able to read this.
All right.
So by putting ourselves in Hannibal shoes,
we could figure out that his heart
attack strategy was done that was weekly
dominated. He's going to choose easy, so
we should defend easy. Having said that,
of course Hannibal went
through the mountains,
which kind of screws up the lesson but
too late now.
All right,
now that I promised you we'd
get back to the, the uh,
the game from last time.
Yeah.
All right, so what do we want where we
got to so far on this past, we know,
we know from last time that you should
not choose a dominated strategy and we
also know with probably
aren't going to choose a week.
You don't need to strategy.
And we also know that you put yourself
in other people's shoes and figure out
that they're not going
to pay off strongly,
strictly or weekly dominated strategy.
That seems a pretty good way to predict
how other people are going to play.
So let's take those ideas and go back
to the numbers game from last time.
Now before I do that, I don't need
the people at home to see this.
But how many of you were here last time?
[inaudible] I asked the wrong question.
How are you were not here
last time? All right, so, uh,
we handed out again that game we ended
out again the game with the numbers,
but just in case, let me just read out
the gate. The uh, the game, you play it,
this was the game you play without
showing your neighbor what you're doing.
Put it in the box below a whole
number between one and 100.
We will in fact have calculated the
average number chosen in the class.
And the winner of this game is the person
who gets closest to two thirds times
that average number, they will win
$5 minus the difference in pennies.
All right, so everybody filled that in
last time. And I have that choice is here.
So let's just before we reveal who won,
let's discuss this a little bit.
That'd be come down.
Houses have to be off the stage.
I'd figured out it's got the mix up about
a second. Let me get some mics ready.
All right. So, um,
let me find out some people here
and see what people did a second.
Or you can be honest here since I've got
everything in front of, in front of me.
So how many of you chose some number?
Like a 32 33 34?
Actually, I tell you,
wait, nine of you did.
So should I read out the
name if I embarrass people?
All right, so, so, uh, our,
we've got Lynette's uh, liquor. Hussan
we've got Christian bargin. Is that,
there's nine of you here is try to get,
how many of you,
how many of you chose numbers
between 32 and 34? Yeah. Okay.
So if you're not a number, you don't know
these things. Some hands up. All right?
Just keep it,
keep your hands up a second.
Even hot headed up there and those people.
All right,
so let me ask people why we're
here. Can we, can we can, we can,
can you get their hand into
the guy? What's your name?
If we get him to stand up,
stand up a second and shadows the cost
me. Hey, what's your name? Chris. Chris,
you're on this list somewhere. I'm you're
not in this lifetime. I know. Mine.
What did you choose? I think I chose 30
okay. 30 is, that's pretty close. Okay.
So why did you choose 30 cause I thought
everyone was going to be around like
the 45 range cause 66 is two thirds or
right around of a hundred and then we're
going to go two thirds less than that.
And I did one less than that one.
All right. Okay. All right, so
let's look at that. Thank you.
Let's get one of the others are,
there was another one in here.
Can you just raise your hands again?
The people who are silver rounds
33 34 the somebody in here.
Can we get you to stand up and who
you are between Mike said. Yup,
go ahead, shout it out. What's
your name? Festival. Ryan.
Ryan, I must have you here as well.
And if mind, what did you choose?
33 or 33 are you, did you are
Ryan low? You are around. Okay,
this is good.
Go ahead.
I thought similar to a Chris actually and
also thought that if we got two thirds
and everyone was choosing numbers in
between 100 and up 33 would be around the
number.
All right, so just just to repeat the
argument that we just heard, again,
you have to shout out more than,
I'm guessing people didn't
hear that in the room.
So let me repeating to make
sure everyone hears that.
And reason for choosing a number like
33 might get, might go as follows.
If the people,
if people in the room choose randomly
between 100 then the average is going to
be around 50 say and two thirds of
50 is around 33 33 in the third free.
All right, so that's a pretty
good piece of reasoning. Alright,
what's wrong with that reasoning?
What's wrong with that?
What's wrong that can we,
uh,
can we get the guy or the woman in the
striped shirt here? Yeah. Yes. I'm sorry.
We have not a woman for
a while so can keep,
even if everyone else had
the same reasoning as you,
it's still going to be way too high.
All right, so, so in in particular,
if everyone else had the same reason
as you, it's going to be way too high.
All right?
So if everyone else reasons that way,
then everyone in the room would choose
a number like 33 or 34 and in that case,
the average would be what? Sorry. Uh,
so the average we have just to show
that two thirds of the average would be,
would be what? Something
like 22. All right.
So the flaw in the argument that
crest and Ryan had a little bit,
it isn't a bad argument, it's
a good starting point. But
the floor in the mistake,
in the argument, it was the
first sentence in the arguments.
The first sentence in the argument
was if the people in the room shoes or
random, then they will
choose around 50 that's true.
The problem is the people
in the room arm's going to
choose at random. All right?
Look around the room a second.
Look around yourself to any of you
look like a random number generator.
Actually from here I
can see something to do.
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna put
all right. All right. All right,
so I'm actually looking
at some of your answers.
Maybe some of you are right on the whole
Yale students are not random number
generators. They're trying
to win the game. All right,
so the unlikely to choose numbers
at random, right? If they,
we also further arguments if in fact
everyone thought that way and if you
figured out everyone was going to figure
out, cause I'm gonna think that way,
then you would expect everyone to choose
a number like 33 and in that case you
should choose a number like 22 how
many of you raise your hand a second.
How many of you chose numbers
in the range? 21 to 23
there's way more than you than that.
I'll start reading you out as well.
The actually about 12 of you raise your
hands is 12 she'll be 12 hands going up
somewhere. There's two, three hands
going up. Four, five hours ago,
there's actually 12 people who chew,
who chose exactly.
22 so can sort of be more if
we include 23 and 21 all right,
so those people, I'm, I'm guessing,
I'm guessing we're thinking this way.
Is that right?
Let me get one of my 22 is up again.
Me.
All right, so here's a 22 is
when, but we want to get this guy.
So what's your name sir?
Stand up.
Stand up and shout Brian.
Yup.
And you chose 22 I chose 22 because I
thought that most people would play the
game dividing by two thirds a couple of
times and give numbers averaging around
the low thirties all right.
All right.
So do you think people are going to
play a plucking away in particular?
If you think people are gonna choose the
strategy of Ryan and Chris and choose
around 33 then 22 seems a great answer,
but you underestimate
your Yale colleagues.
You undress me all y'all can wax and
fax at 22 was was was way too high.
That's way too long. All right, now again,
let's just, it's right. The point here is,
it's a repeat the point here. The point
here is when you're playing a game,
you want to think about what other people
are trying to do to try and predict
what they're trying to do.
And it's not necessarily a great starting
point to assume that the people around
you are random number generators.
They have aims trying to win
and they have strategies to,
let me take this back to the
board a second. So in particular,
are there any strategies
here we can really rule out?
I said we're not millionaires.
We said already people are not random.
Are there any choices
we can just rule out?
We know people are not going
to choose those traces. Uh,
let's have someone here.
We have the guy in, in,
in green on his weight weight fairly that,
yup. Great. Stand up. Give me your name.
Uh, my name is nick and shout it
out to we. We're going here. Uh,
no one is going to choose number over
50 notes, which is number 50. Okay.
I was doing that. That's a, that that
actually got it. Okay. That's fair enough.
Some people did.
That's fair enough.
I wasn't going to get a little bit then.
That's fine.
I just don't think only a
little bit less ambitious.
Somebody said 66 somebody said 66
so let's, let's stop analyzing this.
All right,
so in particular,
this is something about these
strategy choices that are great, sir,
that are greater from 67 at any rate.
All right.
Certainly, I mean a 66 I said,
let's go up a little bit.
So these numbers bigger than 67
what's wrong with numbers?
Bigger than 67 what's wrong?
Raise your hands. Governance. That what's,
what's wrong? You're gonna get the,
the guy in red is right close to the mic.
Stand up. Give me your name. Stand up,
shout it to the crowd and Peter.
Yep.
And if everyone chooses a hundred
it would be 67 all right, good.
So even if everyone in the
number, everyone in the room,
didn't she just randomly,
but they all chose a hundred
a very unlikely circumstance.
But even if they ever want
to chose hundred the highest
the average could. Sorry,
the highest two thirds of the average
could possibly be is 66 and two thirds,
hence 67 would be a pretty
good choice in that case.
So numbers bigger than 67
seem pretty crazy choices,
but crazy isn't the world isn't
the word I'm looking for here.
What can we say about those choices,
those strategies?
6,706 a bigger than 67 68 and above.
What can we say about those?
Choices are to the authority right behind
him. Right behind you. Shout it out.
No pay offs. They have no payoffs.
What? What's the jargon here? It's,
let's use our jargon. Somebody shout
it out. What's the jargon about that?
They're dominated. All right, so these
strategies are dominated. Actually,
there are only weakly dominated, but
that's okay. They're certainly dominated,
right?
In particular as strategy,
like AC is dominated by choosing 67 right?
You will always get a higher up a payoff
from choosing 67 at least as high and
sometimes higher than the payoff you
would have got had you chosen 80 no matter
what else happened in the room.
So these strategies are dominated.
We know from the very first lesson of
the class last time that no one should
choose these strategies that
dominated strategies. All right,
so did anyone choose
strategies bigger than 67 okay,
I'm not going to read out names
here, but turns out four of you did.
And I'm not going to make your way
here. Okay. All right. So okay,
for the four of you did, nevermind,
nevermind. But well, yeah, mind actually.
Yeah. All right. All right.
So once we've eliminated,
once we've eliminated the possibility
that anyone in the room is going to choose
a strategy bigger than 67 it's as
if these numbers 68 through 100 are
irrelevant.
It's really is.
If the game is being played where the
only choices available on the table are
one through 67 is that right?
Is that right?
We know no one's gonna choose 68 and
above. So we can just forget them.
We can delete those strategies.
And once we delete those strategies,
all that's left are choices
one through 67 all right,
so can somebody help me out? Now what?
Can I come out? What can I conclude? No,
I've concluded that the strategy is 68
through 100 essentially don't exist or
have been releases. What can I conclude?
Uh, let me see if I got a mic in here.
That's a stamp. Stand up. Wait for
the mic and he comes to the right.
Good shout out. Then all strategies
45 and above are this also ruled out.
Good. Good. So your name
is Henry. Henry is saying,
once we've figured out that no one should
choose a strategy bigger than 67 then
we can go another step and say if
those strategies never existed,
then the same argument rules
out or similar arguments,
rules out strategies bigger
than 45 let's be careful here.
The strategies that
are less than 67 bought
but bigger than 45 is that
your strategies are not.
They are not dominated strategies.
In the original game in particular,
we just argued that if everyone in
the room shows a 100 then 67 will be a
winning strategy.
So it's not the case that the strategy
is between 45 and 67 our domination
strategies,
but it is the case that they're dominated.
Once we delete the dominator strategies,
once we delete 67 and above.
All right, so these strategies to
be careful here, the word weekly,
yet these strategies are not
weekly dominated
in the original game.
Bye Bye.
Oh dominated
weekly dominated
once we delete
68 through 100
to all of the strategies,
45 through 67 are gone now.
So okay, let's have a, let's have a look.
Did anyone choose? Raise your hands.
Be Brave here.
Did anyone,
did anyone choose a
strategy between 45 and 67
1446 and 67 no one's right now,
but I know some of you take,
cause I've got it in front of me,
right? So these four of you did,
and I won't read out those names yet, but
I might read them out next time. Okay,
so the four, four more people
shows those strategies. All right?
Now notice there's a different
part of this, this argument,
the argument that eliminates
strategies 67 and above,
or second 68 upwards fat strategy.
Just involve the first lesson of last
time. Do not choose a dominator strategy.
Admittedly weak here, but still.
All right? But the second, uh,
the second slice strategies,
45 through 67,
getting rid of those strategies
involves a little bit more.
You've got to put yourself in the shoes
of your fellow classmen and figure out
they're not going to choose 67 and
above essentially the first argument.
That's a straightforward argument.
The second argument says,
I put myself in other people's shoes.
I realize they're not going
to play a dominated strategy.
And therefore having realized they're
not going to pay a dominant strategy,
I shouldn't play a strategy
or between 45 and 67.
So this argument is an in shoes argument.
Okay,
now what? Where can we go now? Yeah.
So let's have the guy in the beard,
but let me the might get him, uh, all
right, and yell out your name. Uh,
Carter,
you just repeat the same reasoning again
and again and eventually get down to
one. All right, well let's,
let's, let's, we'll do that,
but let's go one step at a time.
So now we've ruled out the possibility
that anyone's going to choose a strategy
68 from the bottom because they,
we could dominate is,
and we've ruled out the possibility
that anyone's gonna choose the traffic
between 46 and 67
because those strategies,
because those strategies are dominated
once we've rolled out the dominant
strategies. So we know no one's choosing
any strategies. About 45 it does.
If the number is 46 and above don't exist.
So we know that the highest and anyone
could ever choose is 45 and two thirds of
45 is roughly someone
help me out. They're 30,
right? Roughly 30. All right. So we know
that all the numbers between 45 and 30,
these strategies were not dominated
and they weren't dominated even after
leading the dominator strategies.
But they are dominated once we deleted,
not just the nominated but, but also the
strategies that were dominantly wants.
We deleted the dominated strategist. All
right, I'm not gonna try and write that,
but if you try and write it in your notes.
All right,
so without writing that
argument down in detail,
notice that we can rule out the strategies
30 through 45 not by just examining
our own payoffs,
not just by putting ourselves in other
people's shoes and realizing they're not
going to choose a dominant strategy,
but by putting ourself in other people's
shoes while they are putting themselves
in someone else's shoes and figuring
out what they're going to do. All right,
so this isn't in shoes per capita
where we are here. This isn't
Jane shoes in shoes,
arguments.
At which point you might want
to invent the sock. All right?
Now where's this going? Because we
were able to tell where it's going.
We were able to rule out 68 and above.
Then we're able to route 46 and above.
Now we're able to rule out 31 and above.
All right?
By the next slice down,
we'll be able to eliminate a,
what is it about 20 and above.
All right,
so 30 down to above 20 and
this will be an [inaudible]
in shoes,
right?
These strategies aren't dominated,
nor are,
they don't want you to beat the dominant
his strategies nor we donated the
trashes dominated once we
clean them on his tragedies,
but they are dominated a bunch.
We delete the structures of the dominate
in the neck. You get what I'm doing?
Okay. All right. So where does
this argument going to go? Well,
where's his argument going to go?
It's gonna go all the way down to one.
We all the way down to one.
We could repeat this argument.
We're down to one notice, but once
we've deleted the dominator strategies,
we know I,
I'd said before about four people chose
the strategy and in here about four
people chose their strategy,
but in this range,
30 through 45 I had lots of people.
Lots.
How many of you chose a number
between 30 and 45 all right.
The more than that and your guarantee
you more than that. Matches number two,
put that in 45 all right.
In fact,
the people who chose where we started
off that e three chosen that right?
I had a lot more of you chose numbers
between 20 and 30 so we're really getting
into the, the, the, the
meter, the distribution here.
We're seeing that these are choices that
perhaps are ruled out by this kind of
reasoning.
All right?
Now I'm still not going to quite reveal
yet who won? I want to take this one.
Just one step more abstracts.
All right,
so I want to just discuss
this a little bit more.
I want to discuss the
consequence of rationality in
playing games slightly first
offical for a few minutes.
All right,
so I claim that if you
are irrational player,
by which I mean somebody who's trying to
maximize that pay offs by that play of
the game,
that is simply being rational.
Just being a rational player moves out
playing these dominated strategies.
All right. So the four of you who chose
numbers bigger than 67, his name is,
I'm not going to read out.
Maybe they were making a mistake.
Alright.
However,
however the next slice down
requires more than just rationality.
What else does it require?
Ah, yes. Okay. Can I,
can I get this guy again? Sorry. Shout
out your name again. I forgot net.
Nick shackle that nick. Yep. Uh,
the assumption that your opponents are
being rational as well. Good. Good.
So to rule out the second slice,
I need to be rational.
Yeah.
Myself and I need to know.
Okay.
But others are rational.
Yeah.
Alright. That's a legible. But then my,
what it says is rational and knowledge
that other people are rational.
Now how about the next slice off to
that? Well, now I need to be rational.
I need to know that other people are
rational and I need to know that other
people know that all the people are
rational. All right, so to get this slice,
let's get this next slide here.
I need rationality as some of you know,
that's widely criticized and
the social sciences these days,
I'll be right to assume that people
are rational. But to get this slice,
I need rationality.
I need knowledge of rationality
that's called that k are,
am. I need knowledge of
knowledge of rationality.
All right? How's I go down to further?
I'm going to need rationality.
I need to know people that are optional.
I need to know that people
know that people are rational.
And I need to know the people
know that people know that people.
All right?
And let's just make this more
concrete for you. These people,
these people,
the four people who chose this,
they made a mistake.
What about the four people who
chose numbers between 45 and 67?
What can we conclude about those people?
The number of the people who chose between
45 and 67 so I read out their names.
No, I want, perhaps I've had to know
what can we can talk about the people.
Yeah. Uh, we're never gonna make it.
Let's try and get them making their
come forward as far as you can.
And then it really shattered. Their
classmates are pretty dumb, right? Right.
It's not necessarily that the four
people who chose between 46 and 67 are
themselves thick. Instead, they
think the rest of you are thick.
All right?
And down here,
this doesn't require people to be thick
or to think the rest of you or think
they are just people who
think that you think, sorry,
that just people who think that you think
that that ethic. Alright, and so on,
and again, all the way to one,
we're going to needs very,
very many rounds of knowledge, of
knowledge, of knowledge, of rationality.
Does anyone know what we call it?
If we assume an infinite sequence of,
I know that you know that. I know that
you know that. I know that you know that.
I know that you know something.
What's the expression for that? 10
believe it or not. Technical expression.
Tandem, especially with that in
philosophy is common knowledge.
Common Knowledge.
Chicken never spell.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna win. All right.
Common Knowledge. Common knowledge is,
I know something. You know it. You
know that I know it. I know that unit.
I know that, you know, the, I know
it, et Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
Infinite sequence.
All right.
All right. But if we had common
knowledge of rationality in this class,
then the optimal choice
would have been one.
How many of you chose one? Look around
on the roads. There's paneling over,
like keep your hands up a second.
How many of you chose one?
So actually a lot of you chose one. One
was the modal answer. In this class,
a lot of good shows weren't. All
right. So those people did pretty well.
They must've done, you know, they
must be thinking they're about to win,
but they didn't win.
So it turns out that the
average in this class,
the average choice was
about 13 and a third,
which means two thirds
of the average was nine.
Two thirds of the average was nine.
And some of you chose nine.
So if you are here, stand up, uh,
the following people choose nine.
Um, that's not right. Whether
the people who shows nine,
I've got one here somewhere.
Sorry. There's so many pages
that people, here we go,
the following people shows nines who
stand up if you're here. Uh, and uh,
if you're that person's roommate
or they're not here. All right?
So leashing Chang, at least in
Shanghai here. Stand up. You're here.
And Christopher [inaudible],
Christopher Bharara who can stand up if
you're here and, uh, William official,
are you here? I don't know if he's here
at Jed. Click or you hear jetpack Stein
and Jeffrey Green. Stand up if
you're here and Allison heights,
then I'll put you here. No, Aspen
Heights. Okay. And perhaps add theirs.
And John Robinson. John Robinson.
All right, so these people,
these people want him to come. We
get to that. Can we get good at that?
Up to the camera. Can see you.
There you go. There you go.
Then all the way around and around
wave. Wave to mom at home. All right,
can we get a round of
applause for our winners?
[inaudible]
so jade has, has, uh,
trustworthy brought back the $5.
I've got to focus for a second
just to get it here is the $5.
We're going to tie this into nine pieces,
except I get arrested and deported.
They do that. So we're going to find a
way to break this into change later. Okay.
And come and come and claim it
afterwards. All right, but you're on,
you're on title or whatever.
Whatever, whatever that fraction,
whatever that fraction
of $5. All right. Okay.
So why was this after all that work?
Why was it that one
wasn't the winning answer?
Why wasn't one the winning arcs? Let's
have some where we haven't had before.
Can we? Uh, um, we got the
mic in way in the backpack.
Got Mike and they told you on the road
you're on. See if you can put, actually,
yeah, you're good as stand up, shouts,
stand up, shower, go, shied away.
Uh, when would have been
the winning answer? Loud.
Louder one would've been
the winning answer had. Um,
everyone assumed that the,
the average would have been
constantly compounded down to one.
But since a couple of people chose the,
I mean,
not incorrect answers, but
the higher averages, they,
let's push that to 13. So to get all
the way. Good. So to get all the way.
Thank you. So get all the way
to one. We need a lot, right?
We need not just that
you're all rational players,
not as you know each other's rational,
but you knew everyone else. Restaurant.
I mean, I know you will know each
other cause you made at Yale,
but you also know each other well enough
to know that not everyone in the room
is brash on,
you're pretty sure that not everyone
knows that you're rational and so on,
so forth. Right? So it's
wrong. It's asking a lot to
get to one here. And in fact,
we didn't get to one. It had been
previous years we were even higher.
This was the low, that's
where the low, this year,
in 2003 the average was 18 and a half.
And in 2004 it was 21 and a half.
And in 2005 we had a class that
didn't trust each other at all.
I guess because the average was 23 all
right. And this year it was 13 a third.
Okay. We're getting better there, I think.
All right. One Nice thing. By the way,
this is just chance.
I think the media announcer in the class
was nine which is spot on to the median.
Hit this, hit this, bang up. All right,
now what I want you to do is
I want you all to play again.
We haven't got time to do this properly,
even though I've given you this,
the sheets, so write down, but
don't tell us your neighbors.
Write down a number.
Don't talk about yourself.
That's cheating right down a number.
If you haven't got a sheet in front of
you, just write down on your notepad.
Write down a number. Has everyone
written down a number? All right,
I'm going to do a show of hands now.
How many [inaudible], right? Well guys,
we'll get the camera on you.
How many of you chose a
number higher than 67 Oh,
there's the spoil makers. They're not.
Okay. How many of you chose a number?
Higher than 20
how many of you is a
number higher than 10?
How many times a number
between five and 10.
How many of you choose a number between
zero. Which I between one and five.
All right.
How many of you, excluding the
people who chose one last time,
how many of you chose a number that was
lower than the number you chose last
time?
I keep your hands up a second.
All right,
so almost all of you came down.
Why?
Why are we seeing this
massive contraction?
I'm guessing the average number in the
class now it's put about three or four,
maybe even low,
right?
Why are we seeing this massive
contraction in the numbers being chosen?
The woman in greening, I
forgot your name. I'm sorry.
Told us we're not being rational
if we pick a high number.
All right.
All right,
so part of it is you yourselves have
figured out some of you that you shouldn't
choose a high number, right?
What else though? What else?
What else is going on here? Let's
get somebody, uh, um, there's,
there's a guy waving his arm out value.
You want to stand up behind the hat?
Hi. Yeah, yeah, Yup, Yup, Yup.
Because we've repeated the game. It's
true. We repeated it, but it's true.
We repeated it.
But one of what is it about repeating
or what is it about talking about this
game that makes a difference?
I mean has it the here.
I think what makes the difference is not
only do you yourselves know better how
to play this game now,
but you also know that everybody around
you knows better how to play the game.
Discussing this game raise not
just each person's sophistication,
but it raised what you know about
other people's sophistication.
And you know that other people now know
that you understand how the play the
game.
So the main lesson I wanted to get from
this is that not only does it matter
that you need to put yourself in other
people's shoes and think about what their
payoffs are.
Huh?
You also need to put yourself into
other people's shoes and think about how
sophisticated are they at playing games.
And you need to think
about how sophisticated do
they think you are playing
games and you need to think about how
sophisticated do they think that you think
that they are playing games
and so on, right? This level
of knowledge, this, these,
these layers of knowledge lead to very
different plan the game and to give it,
make this more concrete. If a firm
is competing against a competitor,
it can be pretty sure that that competitor
is a pretty sophisticated game player
and knows that the firm is itself.
If a firm is competing against a customer,
let's say for a non prime loan, perhaps
that assumption is not quite so safe.
It matters.
It matters and how we take gain through
to the real world and we're going to see
more of this as the term progresses.
Now I've got five minutes.
Do I have five minutes left? I've got,
so I've got five minutes to district.
A little small aside here.
We've been talking about knowledge and
about common knowledge and I just want to
do a very quick experiment to
everyone stay in their seat.
I'm going to get two TA's up here.
I want to get la and and uh,
and up here and we're going to sh I wanted
to show that common knowledge is not
such an obvious a concept as I've
made against him on the board.
Come up on stage a second. You can
leave the mic. It's okay. All right.
Here we have two of our tas actually is
the two head TA's and I want you to face
forwards. You don't see what I'm
doing exactly. Okay. All right.
I'm about to put on their heads a hat.
All right.
All right,
here's a hat on his head and
here's an a hat on Kaiser.
It's moving this way so they're in focus.
All right.
Now you can all see these hats and they
can see that and if they turn around to
each other, they can see
each other's have. All right.
Now I want to ask you the question here.
Here is the facts.
All right,
so is it,
is it common knowledge?
Is it common knowledge that isn't common
knowledge that at least one of these
people has a pink hat on their head?
Is it common knowledge?
So I claim it's not common knowledge.
What is known here?
Well,
I'll reveal the fact that you've now
that in fact Allie knows that Chi has a
pink hat on his head.
So it's true that Allie knows that that
is one person in the room has a pink
capital in their head.
And it's true.
That kind knows that Allie has a pink
hat on his head. They both look absurd,
but never mind.
But gnosis that Allie doesn't know
the color of the hat on his own head.
Right. So even though both people know,
even though it is mutual knowledge,
that there's at least
one, perhaps pink cat, uh,
in the Roman lay doesn't
know what kind of seeing.
So Allie does not know that Chi in knows
that there's a pink hat on the room.
In fact, from audience point of view,
this could be a blue hat. So again,
they both knew that someone in the
room has a pink hat on their head.
It is mutual knowledge that there's a fee.
There's a pink hat in the Roman,
but Allie does not know that.
Kind of knows that he's wearing a blue or
a pink hat, and Chi does not know that.
Allie knows that Kai
is wearing a pink hat.
Each of our hats, each that own
hats might be blue. So notice that.
Common Knowledge. Thanks guys. Common
Knowledge is a rather subtle thing.
Thank you. All right, come on.
Now. There's a subtle thing.
Mutual knowledge doesn't
imply common knowledge.
Common knowledge is a statement about
not what I know it's about what do I know
the other person knows that I know that
the other person and so on and so forth.
And even in this simple example where
you might think it's all vs become a
knowledge, it wasn't common knowledge
because there was a pink hat on the road.
Does anybody have a smaller
siblings or children or their own?
They can have a pink cat at the
end of the class. All right,
we'll see you on Wednesday.